el camino para la legalización de la
marihuana en Colombia ha sido largo y
complejo en 1986 la ley 30 que adopta el
estatuto Nacional de estupefacientes
Reguló el uso de la marihuana
estableció la dosis para consumo
personal de Cannabis en máximo 20 gramos
la legislación además permitía el
cultivo de 20 plantas
en 1994 el gobierno despenalizó la
posesión y el uso personal de la
marihuana pero no su comercialización
el país sudamericano también abrió paso
al uso terapéutico de la planta en 2016
la marihuana medicinal fue legalizada su
uso puede ser autorizado por una receta
médica el entonces ministro de salud de
Colombia Alejandro Gaviria defendía así
el paso que daría la nación da un cambio
cultural que se está dando en todas
partes que obliga a actualizar nuestras
leyes y que obliga a cambiar la forma
como se ha regulado el consumo en
particular el consumo de marihuana
medicinal entonces de alguna manera
Colombia se está poniendo a Tono con el
mundo desde entonces los intentos de
legalizar su venta y producción se han
multiplicado sus Defensores aseguran que
sería un cambio de paradigma en el país
por un lado argumentan que se trata de
una manera de propiciar un consumo
responsable además de reducir el acceso
a sustancias consideradas más peligrosas
como la cocaína y la heroína
y por el otro señalan que ayudaría a
combatir el narcotráfico en uno de los
principales países productores de
marihuana en el mundo
la política prohibición instalada
encarecido un producto que sin control
Estatal ha enriquecido y potenciado a
organizaciones criminales que siguen en
expansión en el mundo sus ganancias
estimadas por última vez en 2009 eran de
84 mil millones de dólares anuales la
regularización sin embargo ha tenido
grandes detractores que alegan que su
consumo acarrea problemas de salud y que
legalizarla promocionaría su consumo